[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look then at
what is on the front pages time to see
what is making the headlines with the
Guardians Deputy political editor
Jessica elgot and the deputy editor of
conservative home Henry Hill welcome to
both of you uh no get no surprises of
course as you might expect the financial
times previews tomorrow's budget Jeremy
Hunt's first as Chancellor in which he
is expected to increase investment in
businesses in what's being described as
a budget for growth crying out for help
that's the front of the mirror a message
to the chancellor to be fair to those
who need it most similarly the telegraph
leads with hunt faces Revolt over tax
rise in budget the guardian highlighting
the 4 billion pounds worth of child care
uh funding expected to be announced for
the parents of one and two-year-olds in
England the time says more free child
care to get parents back in jobs the eye
also focusing on child care and the
expected announcement of an extra 30
hours a week for toddlers
as does The Daily Mail the headline free
preschool child care in back to work
budget meanwhile the express calls it
Hunt's carrot and stick to get Britain
growing and with its tongue firmly in
cheek City am says let's hope this one
goes better than Liz and quasi's a
budget for growth there the title there
the Metro has the story of the American
drone uh downed by a Russian fighter jet
over the Black Sea near Ukraine come on
to that a bit later on just a reminder
though by scanning the QR code you'll
see on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us so let's
head straight to Jessica and Henry lots
to talk about with a budget for growth
it had been billed as a budget for work
or to get people back to work and
Jessica part of that many of the papers
picking up on is the help for child care
which many parents would say is
desperately needed
yeah so this was a story that we broke
this afternoon and and the treasury
seems to have given everybody else the
nod that it's right
um uh and that this is something he'll
announce tomorrow a four billion pound
expansion of free child care for one and
two year olds at the moment a lot of
parents don't get any help at all for
one and two-year-olds some of the
poorest households do get some help for
two-year-olds but um it's only really at
three those three hours kick in and this
plan would give 30 hours a week the same
parents or three-year-olds get to one
and two-year-olds increase funding as
well
um for providers which is a big ask of
the sector because essentially they've
been saying you know while the treasure
has been mulling on these plans you know
we're not paying our staff enough you're
not paying enough for these three hours
and therefore
um providers are having to close because
of that so it is a it's a costly thing
to do if you're gonna up the how much
you paid providers and expand how many
free hours you give to parents but it's
a huge boost it will save many many
families hundreds of pounds a month yes
providers having to close or charge
parents the nominal extra if you like to
top up because the money the government
gives isn't quite enough and the time's
also picking up on that more free child
care to get parents back in jobs you
know how will people feel about this as
a giveaway policy do you think Henry
well I think the reasons that just set
out it will obviously be popular Child
Care is something that a lot of people
struggle with and if the government's
priority is getting people back into the
workforce then providing more support
for parents to allow them to do that is
obviously a good thing I think this is
another example though of just how the
treasury having to spend lots of money
to make up for the this what should be
easier policy decisions that they just
won't make right because ultimately Liz
trust tried to slightly deregulate Child
Care bringing the the number of children
an individual carer could look after
down to
um the the Norms in that distant country
Scotland
um and that has continually failed every
time it's been attempted and therefore
this is more expensive and therefore
despite huge pressures on the on the
public person you know the the fact that
they're going to absolutely deliver
these public sector pay Rises at some
point and all the rest of it they're
having to throw four billion pounds at
this policy will it be enough to
actually make this sustainable over the
long term I don't know but it but it is
a good retail offer and it does matter
to people but it's a it's it's
fundamentally a sign of pumping more
money we don't really have in into a
system that politicians are afraid to
reform
and the details of this um the times
tells us that hunt believes that child
care is key to unlocking growth and
under the plans the free child care will
be available to all parents of children
aged one and two provided they earn less
than a hundred thousand pounds each and
both parents work for 16 hours a week at
present the 30 hours of free childcare
offer is only available to parents of
those aged three and four so certainly
bring it down the age range and
encouraging those with younger children
to head back to work earlier
um that the the budget for for work or
driving people back to work
um he has said in a statement this
evening will focus on disabled people
those with long-term health conditions
parents as we've discussed the over 50s
as we discussed last night because of
the pensions changes and also people on
Universal Credit but the main thrust of
it as we head to the financial times is
to unveil a budget for growth now you
might say that's a something of a sop to
the trussides who've been who are
smarting about the corporate tax
increases which are due Jessica
yeah and this is yeah and they're also
you know that you're not seeing those
kind of big headline tax cuts that a lot
of Tory MPS
um do want to see I think you'll all
you'll see you will see I think a little
bit more of the kind of trust budget
um and perhaps in a kind of slimmed down
version than we might have expected to
be resurrected so there will be some of
that uh deregulation for for housing uh
the very Niche nutrient neutrality which
which many Tory MPS uh blame you know a
hangover from EU law that seems to stop
some housing getting bills
um investment zones we remember them
from the other budget so there's lots of
there is stuff that was in it
um that is kind of finding its way back
into the treasury's thinking um but one
of the things that is not uh for moving
so it seems is is this plan to increase
corporation tax from 19 to 25 and to end
that super deduction which was offering
a big tax relief extra box relief on on
companies purchases so
um I think we're going to get something
to replace that but still but still um
it's it's something that touring P says
is one of the things the holding back
growth holding back foreign companies
from investing in the UK yeah still
Express um talks about Hunt's carrot and
stick to get bitten growing and working
in the treasury announcement tonight the
changes are expected to encourage
benefit claimants to move into work or
increase their hours with increased
sanctions enforcement and work coach
support and the child care costs on
Universal Credit to be paid up front but
if we go to the Delhi Telegraph and pick
up on the complaints about corporation
tax and the failure to reduce taxes uh
the telegraph is talking Henry about a
Revolt uh tell us what that might be um
he's saying suggestion that the Le'Veon
companies the corporation tax increase
will have a chilling effect on the
economy at the opposite of growth
yeah well so there's sort of two sides
to this the political side is that yes
the trust sites and there are still you
know quite a lot of them um are smarting
from from the very abrupt nature shall
we say of her Premiership and the mood
decision by Machine Jeremy Hunt to move
away from her vision and they truly
believe that conservatism means
delivering lower taxes and that that
will that will drive growth and so
they're going to try and put pressure on
the government but I think the other
issue is just that you know we hear this
is going to be a budget for business and
yet you know a lot of the headline
issues coming out so far are not
particularly business friendly whatever
you think of the of the increase in
corporation tax rate that's not
pro-business ending the super deduction
is not pro-business even if it is
replaced with full expensing which
basically means that companies can claim
I think 100 of the value of the capital
Investments they make against tax
um and there are things that the
treasury could do you know they could
for example raise the Threshold at which
small businesses have to register for
vat currently there's a huge cluster
clustering effect of businesses which
are deliberately not growing because
they don't would have to start charging
v80 to their existing customers if you
raise that you would allow smes to grow
and we haven't yet seen much of that
either because there's a fundamental
tension between the treasury's needs to
get Revenue in and the idea of you if
you let the if you let if you give the
company some rope now then they will
generate growth and that growth will pay
off in one to five years time so I think
a lot of conservances are concerned yes
some of them are just angry trough sites
but others are concerned that actually
it's very easy to say the word growth
every politician says the word growth
you're not going to find many
politicians who don't like growth in
theory but you know there's a reason we
haven't had it for so long and that's
because an awful lot of the policies
that actually uh militate against growth
are individually very popular and this
housing thing is actually just another
example you know instead of just
scrapping this requirement that the EU
courts came up with they're coming up
with a complicated balancing and
trade-off scheme now yes that might help
but that's still going to involve more
costs for councils more costs for
planners more costs in the process and
it's going to mean that we're still
behind on house building where we were
before that judge was handed down
yeah um the city am picks up on a budget
for growth uh with that comment let's
hope this one goes better than Liz and
quasi's and certainly in a statement
Jeremy Hunt suggested that the Autumn
statement last year was to bring
stability and this one is to bring
growth and just very quickly The Daily
Mirror Jessica just very very quickly if
you can because the backdrop to all of
this of course is strikes in multiple
sectors
um public sector staff going off
yeah and it points out that isn't
anything that's identified so far for
public sector workers although there is
a settlement that will come for them for
this next year but there's there's big
strikes going on tomorrow tube a teacher
strikes
um and it's not a great the backdrop of
that industrial Strife is not a great
one
okay love him brief thank you very much
indeed over running as you can see lots
more still to come though a major
diplomatic incident as a Russian fighter
jet shoots down an American drone uh not
shoots down policies uh nudges it anyway
we'll discuss that next
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Jessica
elgot and Henry Hill
um Henry pick up if you can on the front
page of the Metro then the incident of
the two Russian Jets and the U.S
unmanned drone over the Black Sea
yeah so this story is sort of remarkably
on brand for what we've learned about
Vladimir Putin's war machine because you
originally hear it and you think oh my
God the Russians have shot down an
American drone and then you read on and
you find that actually what happens is
they flew into it
um but basically this highlights the the
two Russian Jets uh have impacted with
it with an American drone and this
highlights the very serious danger that
there is about escalation because
fundamentally both countries have assets
in the area obviously Russia isn't busy
invading Ukraine but America isn't on
the ground but is in the air over the
Black Sea and this is exactly the kind
of thing that that people who are
worried about Vladimir Putin and what he
could do are worried about because they
don't want to see America in the western
NATO countries which have so far held a
very firm line against directly
intervening for all the support they've
given Ukraine getting dragged step by
step into a direct confrontation with
Russia now this is an isolated incident
and there's no sign so far that either
country is intending to to escalate but
it is a sign of the huge Stakes that
there are in that part of the world
many uh
per budget
Mirror Has the Russian jet but it also
has this down its right hand side the
news that Boris Johnson will give
evidence on partygate
um you know some people suggesting a
marathon grilling is what uh he's due
Jessica
and we saw
um a couple of weeks ago or a lot a lot
early last week and that the Privileges
committee has already has got a lot of
very very difficult things to to put to
Boris Johnson including from and
testimony it's taken from uh people
inside his uh Downing Street and uh this
will be televised uh Bryce Johnson has
seen lots of that evidence so
um we can see how those MPS
um are going to grill him on the on the
committee and how on what answers he's
got to to some of the New Revelations
that that have come out
Jessica Henry thank you both very much
indeed plenty to talk about tonight
certainly uh we will see you for more in
the 11 more details obviously of the
budget right now though let's take a
look at the weather